so back to the question tomas
a lot of the times the only thing i
could get on him was to say [ __ ] because
he was way stronger than me
so like after the fighting and i really
couldn't fight no more it was just me
running my mouth because i knew okay you
may have whipped my ass but i'm still
going to say i'm all up in your [ __ ]
head i'm still going to say some stupid
[ __ ] to you while i'm laying here doing
this [ __ ] lock yeah yeah he's around
i'll shut the [ __ ] up but when he gone
[Music]
yeah so it was kind of like that
situation so it's funny to me
like i wasn't gonna let him get over
there
like that's your win like [ __ ] it i you
can take every time you've only proves
my points true what that i don't
remember a lot of [ __ ] no that you could
just be like i don't remember that hey
the truth is valuable reality yeah we
can we can bend it a little bit but i'm
just going based on what the [ __ ] you
told me okay so next question next
question
[Music]